qui nous revenons justement sur le local
en référence au mouvement de grève qui a
eu lieu aujourd'hui en solidarité avec
ce mouvement la ville de la verrière
s'est mobilisé également aujourd'hui la
restauration scolaire la halte garderie
les crèches les installations sportives
mais aussi les services administratifs
de la ville étaient fermées toute la
journée écoutez alain ajaj qui
soutenaient ce mouvement justement à la
verrière il ya beaucoup de salariés qui
seront sans doute en grève dans leur
entreprise à la manifestation
nous accompagnons les salariés
municipaux de la commune qui sont
mobilisés parce que nous sommes inquiets
effectivement de cette loi qui est pour
nous une loi dangereuse difficile dans
une ville où les gens sont sensibles à
l'évolution du code du travail
il faut arrêter de considérer tout est
normal qu'il n'y a pas d'issue que les
décisions sont prises on plus haut
niveau et que c'est comme ça je pense
qu'effectivement à tous les niveaux des
habitants mais aussi les élus c'est
notre responsabilité de dire stop stop
on n'en veut pas